the huge american detention center at
bagram terrified afghans
it was known as afghanistan's guantanamo
bay
and here american soldiers carried out a
hidden war on terror where the first
western tv crew inside the infamous
prison
known for its brutality and torture
[Music]
we squeeze through holes where prisoners
force their way out through the
corrugated walls
how did he get in
they clawed their way to freedom weeks
after u.s soldiers left the base in a
hurry and hours after kabul fell to the
taliban
the cages each housed about 30 prisoners
and inside them were some taliban
fighters arrested by us forces some
viewed as high-ranking terrorists but
also many ordinary afghans just deemed
suspicious
the reinforced cage ceiling allowed the
u.s soldiers to constantly observe the
captives they saw as some of the most
dangerous men in the country held in
these crammed conditions indefinitely
but with no charges no trial and no
justice
no one will ever know
other cells are dark dank pits with
names scrawled on the backs of doors
this one has excrements smeared all over
the inside by its most recent occupant
the smell is quite extraordinary and in
each of these cells there's no windows
and you can completely block out
all light
with these two panels
the place has been ransacked and
everywhere is scattered with pictures of
the prisoners dressed in their orange
jumpsuits as well as all their personal
details
these people look like they've either
been tortured and we found others of
people who appear to have died it's
impossible to know whether they met
their end in bagram
[Applause]
the soundproofed interrogation rooms
still have the fingerprinting and
retinal scanners used to log their
captives
this is the storeroom for the prisoners
and there are pictures of the suspects
who were held all over the place
this is where they got their
prison outfits
orange jumpsuits
there are cable ties all over the place
and to tie their hands
and legs presumably and earmuffs
to deprive them of all noise
many of the taliban fighters are seeing
the notorious detention center for the
first time
looking through the cage ceiling just as
the u.s soldiers have done before them
now they're in charge and it was the
taliban who freed those captives still
trapped here among them it's thought
hundreds of isk captives
it was in these desperate conditions
that the american commanders admit the
thousands held without charge meant many
more were indoctrinated and radicalized
are ready to carry out suicide car bombs
to avenge this they're not scared we do
this for allah not profit
america has lots of money but they're
not willing to blow themselves up the
taliban will sit in a car with a bomb
drive it and set it off we've made
sacrifices before and after this we will
again we are suicide attackers
seeing these cages prompts them to pray
for those who lost so many of their
years inside here
[Music]
some of these fighters are moved to
tears
but more worryingly they also want
retribution
bagram utterly encapsulates the crushing
defeat of the coalition's 20-year long
mission
and those held here who say they were
tortured won't forget and won't forgive
what happened
they put me in a room alone for a month
and made the cell very cold
now i'm mentally sick and my mind is not
working well in the two and a half years
i was held here a lot of damage was done
to my head
within weeks bagram's been virtually
reduced to a scrap yard despite once
being the coalition's main military hub
in afghanistan and now the taliban are
in control victorious and bitter the
american and government of afghanistan
the last government of afghanistan was
really destroying my country my who
killed my brother who killed my
uh religious and do i i want to
make a
against the government of afghanistan
and america
bagrams where many of the coalition
attack missions were launched from but
also where afghans believe shameful acts
were committed in the name of the war on
terror it may also turn out to be one of
the most successful recruiting centres
for anti-western terrorists
alex crawford sky news bagram